also think there's a difference between
ideal and realism like the reality of
people's situation exactly I think a lot
of women would love to be married but
they're real realistically but they made
poor choices
maybe they did get married and maybe it
was a bad time you know you never know
the situation but being a single mom is
a lot of work especially if you have
like three kids yeah
so I'm saying like don't so don't pick
it so don't pick it that's a choice yeah
you don't end up as a single mom by
accident like and you choose who you
sleep with
I don't know I think well maybe if that
husband was better she wouldn't have
left why isn't it maybe
maybe if she was better she wouldn't
have left I think if they both worked on
it then yeah I think we can both agree
people should work on their
relationships before Calling it Quits
but there's you know there's reality
there's a reality and ideal I think